[Music]
um in mother crazy news submitted by I
want [ __ ] oh it's delicious
please by the way if you want to check
it out we have one location in Westwood
one location in Rowland Heights and on
every Sunday were at Smorgasburg in
downtown LA go ahead and check it out
the show Smorgasburg is every Sunday yes
okay I do send foods there yeah yeah and
a night market very safe at night market
yes six to six night market and OC night
markets so so here's the thing people
keep asking me if we're gonna do is send
foods at UM at the six and six night
market but it's like concert with Sony
Asians and we're not able to shoot it's
gonna be hard if y'all compromise leave
us alone you need you need a team that's
like a guys they're shooting they got to
get this done yeah okay a crazy shootout
at a Los Angeles Trader Joe's started as
a dispute between a man and his
grandmother [ __ ] in the grandson just
started blasting each other she was like
I want my organic peanut butter and
someone was like nomogram I don't wanna
[ __ ] is nasty so dry - its it's dry and
it's sweaty yeah cuz of the oil and the
peanut butter it's like separate
February you got a [ __ ] boy this all
day was the [ __ ] though cookie butter
butter Scottie butter thinking what's
that it's good but it has more spice in
it Oh Trader Joe's was this that really
Oh
all those hipsters at their guns kid
hipsters bad so this 28 year old dude
named gene he got into a fight with his
grandmother in South LA and where they
lived together cuz she raised him since
he was nine years old and so apparently
they get into fights often the grandma
knew he had a gun
obviously she never thought he would use
it against her apparently they were
fighting over his girlfriend who would
frequent the house and apparently the
grandmas didn't approve of the
girlfriends listen to your grandma yeah
grandma do you guys listen to your
grandma don't let the [ __ ] take over
man unless he's racist oh yeah racist
grandma I'd still listen to my grandma
yeah so then it was initially reported
that he shot the grandma seven times oh
my god but then now family members are
saying that she only got shot three
times but did she sorta live
that's how Fox heads wait wait tell if
she likes you know if we can laugh or
not she's still like okay haha Oh gram I
was hoping this shouldn't get shot at
all and I just picked her grandma
[ __ ] dodging us in the chest and in
the leg how do you shoot your grandma in
the chest
raised a tissue yeah and you still live
with her well well well we don't know
the relationship well hey they said he
had mental issues right um what if she
was the cause of his way is he white no
okay why cuz I was gonna say they always
say the white gunman has mental issues
oh yeah like that other little [ __ ]
that God like I put it or something yeah
they owned the white boy the crazy white
boy is troubled always troubled child
oh let's feel bad for this kid mm-hmm
but yeah so this guy he ended up
kidnapping is his girlfriend went on his
crazy chase all the way to this Trader
Joe's because he he got into he hit a
pole in the Trader Joe's he got out as
he got out he dragged his girlfriend in
he was having a shootout with the cops
and amongst all that chaos she was
walking into the Trader Joe's there was
a Trader Joe's manager who got caught in
the crossfire and she got killed what Oh
so wait at what point did he shoot his
grandma in the beginning of the story oh
and it was before they got to Trader
Joe's or introduced yeah I just blasted
her oh I see I see okay so he's like
shot his grandma went on a high-speed
chase with the police
suiting up police and then ended up at
Trader Joe's alright did was he put down
or you just kind of rested so then he
ended up taking the people that the
customers at the Trader Joe's hostage
what three hours what yeah he was
negotiating with the cops luckily like
the cops were able to like sneak some of
the people out that's a good place to be
held hostage there are lots of good food
that's good for ya it's like dog
anything that box of frozen bananas it's
covered in chalk oh yeah so good that's
exactly what I would do I get nervous
and I just start [ __ ] eating some
wafers or some [ __ ] yeah yeah I love
those cookies wafers are stress
relieving I'm not gonna I'm gonna go out
better go out with these wait which is
what [ __ ] I'll buy it later or it's
gotta be like I don't know maybe the
rules change if you are in a hostage
situation in a grocery store
oh no eating everything yeah I feel like
I'm gonna get excited like yes the
minute the timer goes off I feel like
the rules change yeah and that's that's
the consolation prize is you can you can
eat whatever you want I'm getting
traumatized but I will eat these organic
something I love those [ __ ] cuties
though have you had the cuties I was
like what joke am I gonna go for here
Organic your mouth shook a little bit I
was debating in between like
strawberries because there's
strawberries in front of me and I was
like now there's a funnier option have
you tried the Ice Cream Sandwich Organic
it's called cutie theme sandwiches okay
and that would have been funny okay been
a hostage situation
no never I work at a bank and you would
have thought oh yeah
you were the closest to that situation
hostage situation I don't think I ever
was I had a guy run in saying like these
guys were looking for him I mean but he
wasn't by holding us hostage he was like
you gotta hide me mm-hmm
it was a barber shop the barber travel
nervous I get the [ __ ] out of my place I
don't know that's comes close to a
hostage situation thank that was a guy
look like that picture of him let me
show you so by the way the manager she
was a 27 year old she had and her name
is her her name was Mele de Mille
so there was a gene gene basically had
to stand off and then somehow the cops
were able to get him to like just they
calmed him down because they promised
him because he'd this dude has mental
issues if he's not really trying to hurt
anybody he was just freaked out yeah he
just freaked out and get a gun he um he
was asking some of the his hostages like
there's this one story about this lady
who had her daughter with her and he
asked her like oh is that your daughter
and she said yes so then he let her go
and then she was holding on to this
other girl and then he asked the same
thing and she Ripper's responded yes
even though that's not her daughter and
he let her go it's like he was like is a
conscience oh my god yeah he wasn't
trying I mean I don't know but the way
they reported it's like he this guy was
just suffering mental issues like he
didn't like he just didn't know how to
handle it reach out and so you're just
asking random questions what's your
favorite TV show like Breaking Bad yes I
love pineapple um piece of it's do so
then yeah this is the Trader Joe's
that's a big-ass Trader Joe's and Silver
Lake and then this is the victim dance
that a Dodger game sounds good
she's got a Dodger game just I should
guess good hug
could be warm honey looks very sweet
poor baby
yeah so they still don't know as right
now who like which bullet killed her was
it the cop sir oh Dan that's sad a
magical one into work the next day and
then your managers God things just not
the same that's why man you never know
what can happen bro that's why you gotta
live life
nude she was just recently transferred
there - oh she's been with Trader Joe's
for four years but just recently she got
transfer there from a different location
yeah if there's a hostage situation that
goes down in a supermarket i'ma run
through the back where the refrigerator
thing is I'm trying to find an exit
there that'd be the first how is he
rounding everyone I would try to just
run through like she was staying in the
front and then so they hostage in the
front
yeah but then there was a lot of people
that were in the back let me just state
their old one of the employees to go
round up everyone else I was in the back
so then apparently she only got some of
them I'll be running away I'll be
running away if I was an employee any
look I'll go get people back I'm about
okay yes sir I would [ __ ] leave have
I ever bother me I'm not I know in the
back would you would you try to do some
hero [ __ ]
hell no hell no Hale we were armed mm I
would try to do save safe people [ __ ]
before I try to confront them I feel
that so you try to get as many people
out yeah you would harriet tubman that
[ __ ] yo and then if I have a cleaner
shot I might throw a Pilates head before
I run out right or not or a bottle bro a
[ __ ] bottle is the big ass like
bottle stuff I do think you're oh [ __ ]
even more accurate with the Apple what
do you think look at bananas and I what
do you think if you had like a team of
friends and so you had a team of friends
and one of them had an axe
alright so then I'm stopping with an axe
yeah so I get all of entry don't ruin
his story you never know Tim there could
be a big five write that story what if
we were camping and I have
I'm a [ __ ] belt alright and I
just so happened to walk into a Ralph's
cuz I needed some apples nothing I just
I needed some green apples cuz we're
gonna make a camera caramel apples at
the camping trip mmm
but I have my axe see that could happen
the [ __ ] little tomahawks all right
one of our friends how to act right
alright let's just say this whole group
was there all right this guy he's
[ __ ] crazy and the cops they're not
there what are we gonna do
run he's shooting people yeah what are
we gonna do there's no there's nowhere
to go
we're we're at the checkout line you
know we're not in the bath standing or
we're sitting hmm are we standing or
sitting no we're standing at the
checkout line he comes in and then boom
immediately he's like don't move don't
move alright and then and then he's like
alright you go round up people in the
back all right so I think we should come
up with protocol if we're ever in that
situation this may be the person that
does that gets something and then throws
it in opposite direction so he looks and
then we all go the other way
no no this is what we're gonna do the
guy with the axe stay as close as
possible to him alright everybody get
naked okay
hella make it and then just go happy
birthday and whooping like what and then
everyone's naked
oh [ __ ] and then if everyone's naked his
eyeline is looking at you
oh no Brandon barks oh no Gio oh no so
everybody's naked oh yeah
lights out I think that's a good plan
it's a good plan the only thing where
I'm scared is if it's just really fast I
think someone slowly has to bring in the
seductive music no you just holy make it
yeah yeah I think blinks and we're naked
yeah surprise oh we are to first though
because I feel like if if I was a crazy
gunman and all of a sudden I saw like a
bunch of naked Asian dudes I'm shooting
Oh
what I've what I pictured is the guys
bent over like this like that and then
you go Yahoo and you [ __ ] talk with
your buddies you're you my agents area
yeah
could they don't be like uh so you want
him - we're good - nice that's a
horrible position I don't know if I
assumed that bizarre enough cuz you know
you know how hard it is to shoot like
like let's say like we'll be far enough
to where he can't really he sucks at us
tell you this hard we get shot and ask
them second woohoo
and then he goes uh see he doesn't have
time to shoot I think we're lost
you might be he might see like this true
he knows all of us doing this he ends up
liking it I mean the whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh what if he does that we're like
it was a [ __ ] a racist then we
kill us I don't know man I'm just trying
to save the world guys one [ __ ] at a
time then you do it why do you involve
us Hey teamwork makes the dream work Geo
hmm not when it's not you don't have to
do you who I'm saying the guys well if
he had how do the yoo-hoo
[Music]